No
[inaudible]
now. Okay.
[inaudible] no, I listen to radio
[inaudible].
I'll continue with here.
Report the first large scale study
comparing the prevalence of absolute pitch
them to normal populations by means
professors. Professor Diana Deutsch.
Diana Deutsch, right? Yeah. I'm going
to turn down my head from Neverland Fan.
I'm a professor of psychology at the
University of California San Diego.
Can you still hear me,
Diane? Okay. Hello Diana.
Studies sound how humans perceive
sound. She's a scientist. She has a lab,
but every so often she will
also release cds, right?
These a cds of audio demonstrations that
she uses in her research and that's why
we called because it was in the production
of her second CD that she stumbled
onto the weirdest phenomenon. Well,
when you do post production is
as you know of of of speech,
you look things, look things,
look things so that you
can zero in on piece. Cool.
That sound too loud. Nita? Unpopular
ss. That sounds too sharp and so on.
So you put things on loops in order to
fine tune the way the speech sounds.
So I had this particular phrase
on a loop and forgot about it.
What phrase was this?
It's a phrase that occurs at the beginning
of the CD in which I say the sounds
as they appear to you. I'm
not any different from those
that are really present,
but they sometimes behave so
strangely as to seem quite impossible,
quite impossible. Now,
I had some hospital so strangely looped
the sounds as they appear to you are not
only different from those
that are really present,
but they sometimes behave so strangely
sometimes behave so strangely.
Just those few words sometimes behave
so strangely and forgot about sometimes
behave so strangely,
sometimes behave so strange.
So here's what happened. Diana leaves
her studio, she closes the door,
it goes into the kitchen to
make some tea. All the wild.
This loop is wearing away in the
background and she's sipping her tea.
She thinks
sometimes if someone's singing
strangely who's singing?
I heard what sounded like song and my
background shoe. That's, wait a second,
that's not singing.
That's me talking that
very phrase strangely,
but at this point sometimes behave so
straight here to be sung rather than
spoken strangely sometimes
behave so strangely.
This is sometimes being so strange, right?
You still hear the words but they're
some words rather than spoken words.
It's weird like it just
switches at a certain point,
three or four repetitions
in, right? It's going,
it's going and then pow
becomes music and then now,
now none of us can get it out of our head.
Like the whole office is like
sometimes VA's so strange
sometimes ca so strangely.
And you know what if you do this demo
and then you go back to the original
sentence that sounds like you know
speech to begin with and when you come to
that very phrase as seemed to be bursting
into song the sounds as they appear to
you and not only different from
those that are really present,
but they sometimes behave so
strangely as to seem quite impossible.
I have to say, this can
continue for months and months.
I sort of sort of like your brain gets
altered for that particular phrase and
it, and it continues to sound like singing
for a very, very long time. [inaudible]
all right, so here we have just one
small indication that music is crazy.
Well, it behaves very strangely,
right? I mean, think about this.
We started with some basic
speech, repeated it a few times.
Somewhere along the way it
leaped into song strangely.
How did it change like that and if that's
all it takes to turn something into
music. And what exactly is music?
Sometimes we, there's some
strange thing. This is Radiolab.
Today's program is about answering that
question or trying to, in any case,
I'm Jad Abumrad here with me.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom and Z.
Robert Krulwich, my partner in crime.
It was a little hard to get out of your
head. I know. It is really cool. I know.
Yeah. Okay, so this
hour, what are we doing?
We are going to try and we will
probably fail. Yes, we will fail,
but we will make an earnest effort to
try to find the ingredients of music.
Both its basis in languages basis in
physics as basis in your brain will look
everywhere we can software trying to
find out what music is made of and why it
touches us so intimately
straight and touches us.
Sometimes not in a good way.
If you've ever had this
experience of going to a concert,
hearing some music and it just
made you upset for some reason,
like irrationally upset, right?
Almost like you want to hurt someone.
If that rings a bell,
there's a segment later in the
show you will not want to miss.
Ah,
this is Radiolab. Stick
around. Hey, be hey.
Oh
Eh,
the
I completely messed up. All right.
Shall we start? Sure. Well first,
thanks to the LaGuardia High
School Chorus and Robert Apostle,
they were the voices you just heard.
We hear more of them later.
So let's explore a little bit more closely
this connection between language and
music. Yes. You think of them as separate.
Great.
The thing is they're really closely
related. So as neuroscientists, mark,
Jude tremble when we speak, we sing,
you know how to use the pitch of your
voice to convey emotion and meaning.
Like, um,
I went to the store just
because I raised the pitch,
the note, if you will, you
interpret that as an interrogative,
a monotonic speech, you know,
talking at the same rate and rhythm
in the same pitch and loudness.
I mean that is not how humans talk,
but humans talking to all kinds of
different ways in different languages.
Each language has its
own musical personality.
German is different than French
is different than Swahili.
And if you look at those
differences closely,
there are all kinds of things we can
learn about music. Tick Diana Deutsch.
Okay. She's recently been
looking at tone languages,
just published her results and
the results are startling. Diana,
before we start, what exactly is it?
Tone language. Okay. In tone languages,
words take on different meanings
depending upon the tones in which they are
annunciated. For example,
Mandarin has four tones and the word mar
in Mandarin means mother in the first
tone. Hampton, the second
CHONe horse in the third tone.
And a reproach in the fourth
tone. Could you say them name?
Would you like me to? Yeah cause you
didn't, I thought you were well up.
You know I have them on CD but I'd
rather hear you say them well. Um, okay.
So excuse my bad
pronunciation that our trial
means
Martha Ma means hemp Ma means
horse and Ma is a reproach.
Huh?
So conceivably if you screwed up the
tones you could call your Mama Horse.
Yes indeed. In fact,
there are quite a lot of jokes where
westerners who don't speak the tone is
right, say terrible things.
And utilizing Hong Kong you have to be
very careful where you will shout at shit
half long. [inaudible]
see this is the basic
difference in English. We don't
really worry about pitch.
We can see our words up here or down here
or glisten it up or bended down in and
it's all the same. Not
so with tone languages.
In any case, this is
where it gets interesting.
One day Diana is working
with some mandarin speakers
and she notices something.
There were these words,
these words that they would say where
they would all hit precisely the same note
with their voices, not just close
to one another either. Exactly.
Precisely and consistently the same,
even on different days. In fact,
would you like me to play for you one
person reciting a list of 12 mandarin
tones on two different
days? Yeah, definitely.
First you have the first
words spoken on Day one,
followed by the same
word spoken in day two.
Then you have the second
word spoken on Day one,
jaw followed by the same
word spoken day two,
so on and that way he,
you can see the consistency is going
to appear as though the words are being
repeated immediately. In fact,
the repetitions occur in
entirely different days.
So each of those word pairs
came out of the mouth.
One person separated by like 24
hours. Oh, much more than that. Um,
something like a week really. And
it was a remarkable consistency.
Jean Jean will,
there'll be like a sing the word mom
always at this note right here. Mom. Mom,
mom. Well, I concluded that basically
this was a form of perfect page.
Yeah. [inaudible] pouch
on the [inaudible] junk,
which I've never quite understood what
perfect pitch is to be honest. You,
you don't know what that is. No.
Should I, and I know I should,
but it's whispered to me as
a musician growing up, uh,
perfect pitches like that. It's
like the thing, it's like the,
anything you wish you had that
none of us have. Basically.
It's like having a tuning
fork in your brain here. I'll,
I'll give you an analogy. Yeah. Okay.
You see this a Coffee Cup I'm holding?
Yeah. What color is it? Brown.
And you knew that how
few of my eyes, right?
You didn't need me to put this Brown
Coffee Cup next to my blue jeans. No,
I didn't know to see the Brown. I mean
it's absolute brown. Absolute Brown.
Perfect pitch. People have that
with pitch. They hear a pitch.
They knew exactly what note it is.
The rest of us have to run this
piano. So if the hero
thing from an elevator,
can they name the note?
Yeah, that's exactly it.
Anything with a pitch like a horn honk,
they could tell you that horn is enough.
Or those church bells, they're
alternating between B flat and B,
and if the faucet were dripping,
they could say that faucet
is dripping in a d sharp.
They don't even have to think about it.
They just know it used to be that
the note names would jump out at me.
Diana Deutsch is actually one of these
lucky people to the extent that it would
even be a nuisance. And
why? Why is that good?
Well, it's really rare.
It only happens like once every 10,000
people here in America. Europe. Yeah,
man. Turning your tongue into a,
you call them and have the people who
have it. Yeah. Well, let's see how many,
how should I say this? If you look
in your music history textbook,
so you will see that every famous
composer like the really big ones, right?
[inaudible] Mozart,
[inaudible], Beethoven,
[inaudible],
they all had it where really
Mendelson, the list goes on on. So if
you have perfect pitch on some level,
you are closer to them.
[inaudible]
he's got the gift. [inaudible]
Danielle, let's get back to
Diana Deutsch. Okay. Okay.
Let's talk about your latest experiment.
That's the one I'm really
interested in. Okay. You see,
you compare Chinese kids to American
kids to see who has perfect pitch more.
So the, explain how this works. You
had a group of Chinese music students,
air group who have American music students
at the Eastman School of music here
in New York. You played
them a bunch of notes,
I imagine in a room and ask them to
guess what those notes were right now.
How did that work exactly?
Well, the test consisted of piano tones,
which began on the c below middle c it
says note and extended up three octaves
or the way to the that note.
That's a big range. Yeah. 36 notes.
Can you demonstrate you're
sure? Yes. Here is six tones,
Eh,
such as where given in the test.
So you would have played those notes to
both sets of kids and asked them to name
the notes without going to the
piano. What were the notes?
Really what these notes were?
D E g shock, c sharp, d sharp.
And g. Um, what were the results? Well,
it turns out the Chinese group far
outperformed the eastern group of those
students who started musical training
at ages four and five 74% of the Chinese
group show perfect pitch,
but 14% of the u s [inaudible] 74%,
the Beijing group was nine times roughly
more likely to show perfect pitch than
the American Jesus. That's a split as
American group. Daggering difference.
It's a staggering difference.
Mm.
And it's your hunch that the difference
is because they speak a tone language.
That's my hat. I mean
the, it's, it's known that
the first year of life say from eight,
six months up to, you know,
a little pastor the year infants learn
features of their native language.
This is a very, very important stage.
Let's suppose that tone and the absolute
pitch of tones is a feature which is
potentially available to anyone.
Babies who are exposed only
to an international language
such as English and not
given the opportunity to acquire tones,
then they're going to be
at a real disadvantage when
they come later on to learn
to take wizard lessons.
So you think that as they're
a data data, let me ask this.
As they're learning their language,
which includes inherently
music to some degree,
they are essentially learning
two languages as they learn one.
Is that right? It's a matter of fact.
If you take the first tone
[inaudible] it's a flat tone.
It's really sung. Yeah.
Compared with English speech,
it's really more like song.
That's what that's always been sort of
the stereotype of the Chinese languages.
It's very sort of sing songs.
Yes. One Boomi soy mean
Guido home bow share, Lambo,
Shirley bow shoe for example,
the third child in Mandarin Ma.
It's sort of like a j type
pattern. The second term,
which is a gentle output
glace ma the fourth toe,
which is a rapid downward place. Ma.
I mean these are all kinds of
musical relationships. Yeah.
Given the evidence on absolute pitch, one
could speculate further and say, well,
may be other features of music are also
enhanced for individuals who start off
learning tone language.
So, so the, here's my big question,
could this explain the
experience that I had?
And I think a lot of people have this
experience when they're taking music
lessons and playing a little piddly
pieces like flares, Yamaka,
and here are these Chinese girls,
right? Her playing rough Monona
you know, the brilliant,
yeah. Is this why? Well, I,
I think it's a viable hypothesis.
I mean evidently it
could be something else.
It could be something else
going on. No, go ahead. I mean,
one could argue that instead
it might be genetic and so on,
but they're seen as such a,
it's such a boring theory,
like always a boring
theory. And furthermore,
we don't have to assume that knowing what
we do about exposure to tone language
in very early childhood as
a, as a, it's just not fair.
And I think we can look
at it another way around
here.
We have a faculty that had been thought
to be confined to a few rare individuals
who are just extraordinarily
gifted, right?
That might in fact be available to any
individual provided they're given the
right exposure, attic critical period.
And that raises the question of what are
the sorts of abilities could be brought
out if we only knew just what to do.
There may be much more human
potential than we had realized.
[inaudible]
Diana Deutsch is a professor of music
psychology at the University of San Diego,
music psychology, music psychology,
and as I mentioned earlier,
she's also the releaser of
two cds. Yeah. Yes. Two CDs,
one's called musical
illusions and paradoxes,
and the other one is called Phantom
words and other curiosities.
What would you put on a CD? Exactly.
She puts these little audio pieces
that she uses in her research.
The stuff I guess that she will play to
subjects as she tests them and she puts
these on cds because they're
kind of fun to listen to you.
This is like an ear test or sort of, we've
actually put a couple on our website.
Well, what do they sound like? We
just it that little sample. All right.
I'll get some samples though.
There is the chromatic illusion.
Ken has a carnival feel to it.
There's also the a Cambiado illusion.
Oh, the can be.
And of course the
phantom word experiments.
[inaudible] none of those pieces are
gonna make any kind of sense unless you
visit our website, radiolab.org
where all will be explained
[inaudible]
coming up,
fashionable French ladies and elegant
dresses threw things at innocent
musicians. I'm Jad, I'm from
Rodan, me, maybe not so innocent.
[inaudible] which, and I
will continue in a moment.
You're listening to radio live
from New York public radio. B u.
N. N. P. R. Sorry.
Right
baby [inaudible] so speeding.
[inaudible] some.
Ah,
hey [inaudible]
[inaudible]
hey,
so Steve's the south.
So
was the hey solos. [inaudible]
sorry.
[inaudible]
baby. Hey
[inaudible] sound [inaudible]
this is Radiolab. I'm Jad Abumrad
and I'm Robert Krulwich. Ah,
program today is about music. What it is,
how it works and what we want
to do next. Did we want to,
we want to stay on the subject,
but we're going to explore
this a little more deeply.
Take a closer look at the connection
between language and music.
We're gonna add touch, touch, and
that will take us to the ear, the ear,
and then into the brain, the brain.
And then to the big question,
the really big question,
why does music or how does
music become a feeling? The
feeling, why do we get such deep
pleasure or deep pain? We will.
They have pain coming up to all simply
because it air pressing against your ear.
All right. We're first. All right,
well there is a psychology professor I
want you to meet at Stanford who directs
the Center for Infants Studies.
There in front old's is her name and
she got it into her head that there is a
kind of deep universal
music inside language.
She discovered it actually at a hospital.
The Max Planck Institute in Munich has
an obstetrics unit which is very popular
among expectant mothers.
Mothers came from the war.
It's if this German hospital then so
they were Turkish. They were Greek,
they were Sicilian.
They were the so called guest workers
and the German society. Of course,
I didn't understand a
word of what they spoke.
As soon as they put the baby down and
no longer had the physical contact,
bodily contact with the child,
they started to sing almost
in one language after another.
Given the babies. I heard these,
I heard them use these
melodies Russian now to reach,
to reach the child to remain in touch
with the baby Yiddish for a period.
So next day I brought my tape
quarter ham for an old,
took her tape recorder from that
hospital and traveled all over the world
recording parents as they talk
to their very little babies.
And it didn't matter whether the parents
spoke a romance language or a tone
language everywhere she
went below the word,
she heard consistently the
same melodies. For example,
I'll start with approval. When a
parent wanted to praise a child,
we would ask the parents to
show the baby they were happy.
Good boy. Now you got it.
Just using their voice.
Show him you're happy with that.
I taught that. He got, he get that I Gardy
[inaudible] Portuguese
bungalow.
And what these things had in common was
that the melody was a kind of a of a
rise fall. Um, good girl. Hi Girl.
Got It. Yeah. Good girl sweetie.
It doesn't matter what words
the parents are saying.
It's always really about this melody
and why that particular melody.
All she knows is that it worked.
There's something about
this melody that that piece,
just the child doing something. There are,
she says other categories that she
discovered. Now with a prohibition.
In contrast, your goal is to stop
the child from doing something.
The category that says stop quite
a different melody. It's short,
it's sharp in musical
terms, it's the Kotto,
but I bet there is the category. Look, pay
attention to that. No, this frequently
use rising pitch. Look Sweetie,
they frequently use
higher pitch at Unicorn.
So far, Anne Fernald has found four
universal melodies that praise,
that stop and call attention and
of course the melody that comforts
[inaudible] and while this may seem
obvious to you, if you think about it,
this is music that is understood by
infants who are just new in the world,
but we all know what it means.
We all know these songs.
We we're used to thinking of
sounds as being about something.
Speeches always about
something, but it feels to me
more like touch.
[inaudible]
touch isn't about something. If you whack
me on the arm in a sudden sharp way,
I'm going to be startled or a
gentle touch has a different effect.
And I think, you know, actually sound
is kind of touch at a, at a distance.
I was in for an old director of the
center for infant studies at Stanford and
when Anne says sound is more like touch,
that turns out to be literally the case.
This is something I learned from a
friend of mine, Jonah Lehrer. Um,
my name's Jonah Lehrer with this
very moment is working on a book,
an upcoming book on art and science on
the connection between art and science.
Do we own it? Do we have
a name for that book?
It's called Proust was a
neuroscientist. Okay. Ansys Jonah,
thinking about sound as touch
more like touch, I asked him,
how does sound get into
or, or touch your brain,
take us on that journey. It's
just waves of vibrating air.
Um, it's just your voice
hatch at a, at a
beginning. Your voicebox compresses air,
not air travel through space and time
into my hair.
The little ton of waves
of diffuse vibrating here
focused and channeled into my
eardrum, which vibrates
a few very small bones
and the little bones transmit the
vibration into this salty seat
where the hairs are and the
hair cells are fascinating.
The hair cells become active when
they are literally bent by weight.
[inaudible]
Ben like trees and a breeze.
And when these hair cells are banned,
charged molecules,
blood inwards and activate the cell.
So the sound triggers the bones,
the bones disturbs the fluid,
the fluid rocks the hairs. Yes.
And then the heres set off
essentially electricity. Yes.
That's the language of neurons.
All those changes from waves
to bones to electricity.
All those things were a trip
on their way to being heard.
It's only when the electricity
finally forms a pattern in your brain.
Only when it's deep inside.
That's when you hear something.
That's okay.
If it feels to me more like touch
sound is kind of touch at a,
at a distance.
Uh,
[inaudible].
All right. Now that we have gotten a
sound and any sound into our heads,
let me ask you the next
really big question. Okay.
Why do some sound and
let's make it music. Okay.
Why does music make so
many of us so often feel
so strongly? Yeah. Like in terms
of what we were just listening to,
like how does all that electricity from
the ear going up to the brain in the
next millisecond become
a feeling? Yeah. Well,
let me introduce you to someone martyred.
Trey Mo actually we heard from him
earlier. He's a neuroscientist.
I'm in the Department of Neurology at
Harvard Medical School and mark can at
least begin to answer this
question, this feeling question.
He's done something really interesting.
He's able to listen to the electricity
as it pools in the ear and shoots up this
big fat nerve to the brain. It's
um, it's kind of a, a popping sound.
He can actually listen to that nerve to
the electricity so faster than I'm able
to do here with my fingers.
[inaudible]
is that a, is that the sounds when
it sounds like, how did they get,
how do they get this sounds?
I actually have no idea.
I guess I sort of tap into the nerve.
This is the sound of sound
entering the brain. Yes.
This is the sound of sound entering the
brain as electricity and little pulses.
And as you can hear, the
electricity has a meter,
but mark is discovered is that when the
electricity entering your brain is even
and regular, regular. This
is the baggage should wait
[inaudible]
yeah, that's regular. Right.
When the meter of the electricity
is regular and rhythmic,
it will arrive in our mind and be heard
by us as a sound that we generally like,
like this nice sound that
in music is known as a perfect fit.
The inputs coming from a perfect fifth
[inaudible]
[inaudible] is very, very regular
like a metronome. However,
and here's where it gets interesting.
When the meter going from the year two,
the brain is irregular, jagged
a with make unpredictable. Let
me hear it. This is jagging
in here. Oh, Jagan which,
oh
yeah, that's true. Yeah.
And what mark has discovered is that
when electrical impulses like that travel
from the ear to the brain,
they will become heard by us,
by our mind as a sound that
we generally don't like,
like that. Don't care for that
one. That's a minor second.
The inputs coming from a minor second
again
is very, very chaotic.
Okay, so let me just sum up
here what I think you're,
you're saying if a sound entering my
brain is disorderly and unexpected,
electrically speaking,
then that would make me
feel uncomfortable. Yeah.
And if it comes in in a
familiar and orderly way,
that will make me feel comfortable.
There does seem to be a relationship
between the kind of electricity as sound
producers and how we
feel about that sound.
Do they have like fancy names for
this? Well, that's a minor second.
That thing you just said,
but did the scientists have names
for pleasant and unpleasant?
A continent is pleasant. Dissonant is
unpleasant. That's not a science name.
That's a music name. Oh, okay. And these
are fixed positions in your ear. Wow.
Meet with me. Be Fixed for
scientists. But you know,
maybe let me just propose this to
you and what people find pleasing.
What people find painful is malleable.
I'll tell you why. I'm going to tell
you a story now. The true story.
It involves a musician, ego, Stravinsky,
who is now considered to be one of the
great composers of the 20th century,
if not the most important
composer of the 20th century.
That's Jonah layer again.
And Jonah tells the story of two
concerts one year apart in the same city,
the exact same piece of music,
the audience who heard it
first and then the audience,
or heard it later on her
totally different things.
So let's begin first at Jonah. How
does this, um, just set the scene?
This is May, 1913 to spring night. It's a,
it's a balmy summer
night. Black Tie costumes.
The women have their fedoras.
This was evening clothes. Yeah.
Well this was the Russian
ballet. This was high art.
And the programs had, this is
a concert about springtime,
but as they settled
into their seats, right?
Turns out that what Stravinsky had in
mind was not spring like honeybees. No.
The spring Stravinsky had in mind was
about change, about radical change,
ritual murder. Literally, that's
what the story of the play is. It's,
it's a pagan ritual where the
end, the virgin gets massacred.
Oh dear.
[inaudible]
but the music itself is fascinating.
The beginning is this very charming
bassoon.
It's a classic Lithuanian folk tune and
it does sound like the earth is warming
and that lasts for about a minute and
then we get some Tutti of flutes and it's
lovely. It's getting a
little more disturbing
and then about three minutes into it
[inaudible]
everything changes.
there's this, there's just an
earthquake. Stravinsky plays this cord
[inaudible]
there's a great story
that went the Aga lab,
who's the head of the ballet roost
first heard this court entrance because
playing on the piano for
him, he asked Stravinsky,
how long will it go on like that?
And Stravinsky looked at him
and said to the end, my dear,
and it literally does that
chord structures, the music,
it's one of the most difficult
sounds you've ever heard. It is.
It is just the stereotype of
desinence. It is. It hurts you, Huh?
Well what happened? Well, after
about three minutes they ride.
They ride it
meaning what? Like they screamed or
through, they screamed. There was blood.
Old Ladies were hitting
each other with Keynes.
One lady on lady should've gotten
hit Stravinsky with a cane.
But once they started screaming,
Stravinsky ran backstage and
by some counselors crying,
Nijinsky was off on the side of the stage
screaming to his dancers to keep the
beat. Dude. Wow. Quite the fiasco.
And the question is why?
Well, this is the feeling question.
Why so much feeling about a piece
of music that, why did they arrive?
You would think that they ride it because
they were hot because they didn't like
those towns because they did.
They thought those dancers were
making strange and odd gestures.
Lo Jonah offers a different
theory. Let me put it this way.
This ride has been talked about
and written about for forever.
But to the best of our knowledge,
no one has ever tried to explain what
happened that night through the lens of,
um, brain chemistry,
brain chemistry. Yeah.
What music can do to a brain. You know,
if you try to imagine yourself or
all you've heard is [inaudible]
even or, and, and the great
romanticism of 19th century user,
um, and then all of a sudden you get debt.
[inaudible].
These are noises you've
never heard before.
It's all very new, but scientists
are beginning. Figure out what
happens in our brain when we hear
noises we've never heard before,
especially dissonant noises,
refine that chords.
Musical chords that are
typically judged to be dissonant,
elicit these wild fluctuations in
brain activities is Yon Fishman.
He is a neuroscientist and he studies
those wild fluctuations in the brain on an
area of the brain called
the auditory cortex.
Let's zoom in to the auditory cortex
for a moment because this is basically
hearing central and when
you're listening to music,
there are all kinds of neurons
during all kinds of things.
One gang in particular
that yarn is interested in.
That's right.
The gang that he suspects gets very
agitated when it hears sounds like these
[inaudible].
These neurons might be the new noise
department because he thinks their job is
to take every new strange unordered
unpredictable noise that comes into the
brain. Figure it out, find the pattern.
There are groups of neurons
whose sole job it is.
This is how Jonah puts it to turn
that dissonant note, dissect it,
take it apart and try to understand it.
We are pattern searching animals
and this is how Yon Fishman puts it.
And so at the level of
the auditory Cortex,
the brain has this daunting task of
having to be able to disentangle this
complex mixture of sound.
Most of the time those neurons
in the auditory cortex succeed
in finding the pattern.
But every so often, and maybe
this was the case that night
[inaudible]
okay, so Robert, imagine
inside the brains,
inside the heads of the people in the
audience listening to the right of spring
that night where all
of these neurons, yeah,
I can hear them trying to make
sense of the new sounds in failing,
not just feeling once or twice, but
over and over and over and over.
The rite of spring keeps being dissonant
all the way through so they can never
get any rest. And when those
neurons fail repeatedly,
there are consequences.
Chemical consequences.
What happens is our neurons squirt out
a bit of dopamine and what does the
dopamine do? Well dope mean,
makes us feel a little dopamine.
Makes you feel happy. That's why sex
and drugs make you feel euphoric,
but a little too much.
And that euphoria turns into literally
a schizophrenia. Really? Yes.
I don't want to oversimplify a
schizophrenia in any way, shape, or form,
but some of our most effective
treatments for work by
suppressing dopamine release in the brain.
So there's some kind of relationship.
Too much dopamine has been shown
clinically to make people feel crazy. Yes.
Maybe that's what happened that night.
On May 29th, 1913 music erupted.
Neurons revolted, right?
Dopamine flooded through.
This is to their brains and
people went mad. Literally Mad.
Let's go to the second night in our
story. The piece does come back to Paris,
right? Yes. How much later after the
riot? Uh, it's from May to March.
Actually it was April. So
it's almost a year later. Yes.
And this time it doesn't
come with the ballet.
This time it's just being performed
as a work of music. So do,
does anyone buy tickets? Oh yeah.
It's, it's, it's, it's gonna sell out.
They do cause a few nights of violent
riots. Can you shut up the situation?
Now the audience is at a
different audience. Uh,
I actually don't know if
the audience is different,
but we can at least say that the audience
is coming to it with a different set
of information. Exactly.
They've, they've been warned
[inaudible]
so for the first time they can actually
sit back and really try to pay attention
to the notes by being willing to listen.
They could hear the orders and patterns
that students get hidden in this work.
They were able to hear the music
and find the orders hidden
underneath this noise.
Was there a riot this time? The second
round? Oh No. Quite the opposite.
Stravinsky was a hero. They carried
them out on their shoulders.
Really? Literally he was,
he was literally, he was
carried on the shoulders and,
and, and the press was glowing
in one year, in one year.
And just one year Stravinsky
had gone from villainous monster
to hipster icon to the extent that
police had to escort him from the concert
hall to keep them safe from adoring fans.
And that was just the
beginning. The the third story,
if you wanted to tell a third story
would be it became children's music.
It became Disney music in 1940 27 years
after Stravinsky caused a violent and
bloody riot.
He was negotiating with Mickey Mouse
over the rights to use his music and
Fantasia, which fantasia just starting
a hippopotamus and a little too to know.
Is that the one? Is it
the mushroom stone? Yeah,
I think it's the mushrooms isn't
mushrooms. Actually we looked it up later.
It was a the part with the
dinosaurs. So how does this happen?
How do you go so quickly from being the
most outrageous thing that literally
maddens people to a
triumph to kid's music?
Yes. I mean the rite of spring is perfect
evidence of the brain's astonishing
plasticity. See, this is the
really cool part of it for me.
If you remember just one bit of science
from this whole thing, remember this a,
those neurons we met earlier, the one
that, the little voices, I liked him.
It turns out those neurons learn
and they learn fast
because they're actually part of a
larger network of brain cells with a very
technical name called the
Cortico fugal network.
And what this network does is
it's always sort of monitoring,
listening to the sounds that are coming
into the brain and tuning those neurons
to better hear those sounds.
Trying to get the station on the
radio just to getting it just right.
[inaudible]
so our neurons literally adjust.
Literally we're talking then
biochemical engineering sense.
So if on that first night you just hear
the right as pure noise all the way
through from beginning to
end. If you're listening,
if you're letting your cortical
fugal network do its job,
it can actually resculpt your brain and
let you hear the patterns better as a
symphony evolves.
Is it fair to say that this is a sort
of tug of war that an artist comes,
create something that is
new and unpredictable and
strange and maybe noise ish
at first hearing and the
artist is thrilled to be
new in that way and then the
brain ruins it all slowly but
surely by making it familiar.
And whether the brain a pours the new,
the brain constantly wants to assimilate
every experience we've ever had into
every other experience.
And I think Stravinsky realized it was
the purpose of the artist to challenge a
brain, to break the brain out
of its conservative cycle.
The astonishing thing to me is here you
have an artist like Igor Stravinsky who
comes to town intentionally trying to
get people to sit in their seats and
really listen to music.
And the strategy he chooses
is instead of pleasing them,
he wants to put them in a little bit
of discomfort or real pain even. Right?
And indeed they not only listen,
they riot, but within a year,
and this is the sad part to me,
within a year it's easier to hear.
Suddenly it's pleasant.
Suddenly they like it and suddenly you
s driven ski is robbed of his newness.
Why is that sad for you? Well,
because it's kind of, I don't know.
I never thought of the brain as the
enemy of the artists before with Mia.
But I can give you a different
interpretation on this. I mean,
here comes a guy who offers
up the most dissonant,
stabbing, percussive, painful music
to anyone had heard to that point.
And we learned to love him.
But because of that make you sort
of feel like pride. No, I know.
I mean like our brains
can decode anything.
We learned to love it only
because it's well-made. Yeah.
But just random car honks. I don't
think you could really appreciate that.
I disagree. Or you think it
would be like just having,
have you heard the music that
was written after Stravinsky?
Okay.
It's even worse than
what you just did. Yeah.
But my brain has never accommodated
that. But some people love that stuff.
And my only point is that if there,
if there are these like fixed poles,
our ear
between continents and dissonance, which
is how we started this whole thing,
and now we end up learning that our
brains can override that to such an
astonishing degree.
Well then culture wins.
Culture beats biology. But to me it's sad.
Sad for the artist. It's not sad for us.
Hmm.
It's sorta like the artists and the
brains are that kind of eternal struggle.
[inaudible]
special thanks for that
story too. Jonah Lira,
who is a regular radio lab contributor
and he's the author of the upcoming book,
Proust was a neuroscientist, a
posted down Yossi and [inaudible].
I'm Jad Abumrad Robert Grove, which,
and I will continue in a moment.
You're listening to radio
from New York public radio.
NPR.
Okay.
This is Radiolab. I'm Jad
Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
Today I program's about music.
We ended our last segment with a look
back at a very famous riot in 1913 and a
composer, Igor Stravinsky,
whose primary objective was to create
something new and dissonant and
disturbing. Right now
we'll present the opposite,
the off the unscrew the head tie,
Stravinsky, in a way. What we mean is he,
we're going to introduce you to
a guy who has invented a new,
radically innovative and ingenious
way of creating something old.
His name is David Cope.
He works and teaches composition at UC
Santa Cruz in California and recently our
producer Ellen was in the area
and it is a beautiful area. It's,
it's 22.5 miles. Well, and she
paid him to visit extraordinary.
And they're like birds. We've
got a, we've got, you know,
I have nest in each window, each
here. Sure. And this one's over here.
You can take a look again, like come
back in. It's okay. It's just me.
Come on kid back in your
nest. Um, she's usually,
she'll just hop right back in
when she hears me talk. You're,
aren't you going to listen to me? Oh,
this was beside the point because we'd
actually come to talk to David Cope,
not about nature, but actually about
something unnatural that he'd done,
which started about 20 years ago,
the 1980, I had a,
a commission for an opera
which involved actual money,
which we had been given up
front. And which by the way,
since I had four small children,
I had already spent and uh,
for the first time in my life,
uh, I suffered a composer's block.
It was like somebody just shot me or your,
I should be at the height of my creative
power and I can't find a reason to
compose. A first note is c sharp
started no more interesting.
You'd see natural or d and notes
just didn't make any sense to me.
I was really lost. I can't
think of anything worse
cause it's not my profession,
it's what I am.
A short time later, David Cope Party
and he finds himself talking to a guy who
programs computer and he was asking me
how things were going and I just simply
said, ah, you know, it's a nightmare.
And we talked through it, you know, and I,
I think I must've initiated it by saying,
are there any intelligent
programs out there that could,
I could possibly use to help
me through this? And he said,
well there aren't any intelligent
programs period. But he said,
you don't really need one, don't you
really just need some kind of a foil.
He called it that.
And I, I really had an epiphany.
What I would do is build not
so much composing engine,
but an analytical engine,
a computer. It took them years to
build. And that's it. This is, this is,
this is Amy right here. This is this
Emmy is the computer's name, spelled e.
M. I. M.
E is an acronym for experiments in musical
intelligence and what he built me to
do is analyze things. This
is specifically notes,
treat notes like data. In other words,
he'll feed me a bunch of sheet music.
For example, buck, Krells,
any will then convert every single
note on the page into numbers. Right.
Can you describe what you
see on the screen? Well,
there's thousands and
thousands of numbers.
There are five numbers for each note
numbers which represent all kinds of
things. The on time, the pitch,
the duration corral becomes a huge,
massive information. Which Emmy then
sorts through looking for patterns.
Note four 50 always seems to be falling
by note four 56 loud and then soft.
She will find the patterns. Every composer
has them, the little things they do,
the DNA of
the individual
now finding all the patterns,
mapping the creative DNA of a
composer is in and of itself.
Not all that interesting. It's what
happens next, which is the spooky part.
Cope hits a few buttons and all
the DNA starts to recombine.
Ghosts stir in the machine,
any molar,
any Beethoven,
[inaudible],
Ethan Scott, chaplain
and of course his favorite Bach of course.
Then I became very excited about this
prospect and immediately put in some coke
and sure enough my opera,
which had taken ion. No,
by the time I was putting in the Copa,
it was maybe five years and past. Uh,
the opera was written in about 10 days.
So as a demonstration,
I'm going to play for you the f the
opening of the corral that was composed in
1987, uh, in the style of Bach.
And one of the first ones that
came out of the program. Now,
this corral was so bad, it sounded to
me when I first heard it that I, I,
I threw it away at Britain, the
trashcan. And then I said, well,
there's something about that that I
kind of like and I pulled it out again.
I thank God I did because this is my,
one of my favorite pieces
the program ever produced.
So here's what it sounds
like as a machine, but plant
[inaudible] just a huge
rigidity of machine,
like n****r of the meter being processed
and all the notes being processed in
precisely the right time with
these timbers this mornings,
which are egregious. I mean,
they're just terrible. [inaudible]
now I'm going to play for you the same
corral as performed by a group of singers
a while later.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
same piece of music. Incredibly human,
personally musical going someplace
intriguing. I want to hear more.
The second one. I'm glad I turned
off the first one. One idea.
Oh,
[inaudible].
Yes sir. Yes. Oh, the number
of negative reactions is far,
far outnumber the positive reactions.
Remember recall one in particular?
One that Oh yeah, it was at a conference
in Germany in which, uh, colleague,
uh, he hit me in the
nose, his finger. I'm a,
I'm pretty much a coward physically.
Yeah. You know, he was bigger than I,
so it was, it was a quite a
moment, but there have been many,
many occasions, you
know, shouting matches.
If you've spent a good portion
of your life being in love with,
you know, these dead composers.
I mean, that sounds horrible,
but you know what I mean?
And along comes some Twerp who claims
to have this little piece of software
would use, isn't in much at all that
can, can, can move you in the same way.
Suddenly you're saying to yourself, yeah,
Whoa,
what's happened here? Certainly my, my,
my relationship to the original pieces
of music is cheapened in some way.
I mean,
what is Chopin really just nothing more
than a bunch of cliches thrown together.
[inaudible]
I hurt with them in a way
and when they hurt, um,
I feel successful
and I also feel very bad. I mean,
I'm missing with some pretty powerful
relationships here and doing so in a
mechanical way. If I had done
it myself as a human being,
these individuals could probably live
with it because after all, they could say,
well, you know, he's just really
good at that sort of thing.
But somehow using hell, you know,
or some version of how
is the ultimate insult.
There is nothing intelligent
about my program in this lightest.
Nothing intelligent about it.
I could do everything it
did if you gave me 10 years.
I just don't have that amount of
time. I'd rather spend five minutes.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible]
we did a concert here at Bach,
at Emmy Bach and the
Middle Moon is just a dorm.
I mean it's just lovely. And,
and a friend of mine was sitting in
the back of the hall next to an ancient
lady.
She must've been in her eighties late
eighties and she couldn't read very well.
So she hadn't read the program.
[inaudible] she really just was at this
concert because friends told her she
didn't know what was all
about or anything like that.
But she knew all about music
and she loves it. Bach and,
and she listened to that
[inaudible]
and she turned to my friend and said,
oh,
that was just beautiful. And
my friends started to say,
but do you know that it
was? And then he said,
well, the hell with that.
[inaudible]
it was the reaction that I hope people
will have a hundred years from now. If,
if by some weird fluke this stuff hangs
around long enough to still be around
them. Um,
but I hope we can put aside all
this machine trapping the stuff
and, and really just deal
with the music itself.
Piece was produced by Jonathan Mitchell
and recorded by our producer Ellen Horn.
David Cope composes and teaches
at UC Santa Cruz in California.
If you'd like to hear any
more compositions by his
computer Emmy and there are
hundreds you can visit our
website, radiolab.org there
you will find Emmy Bach,
Amy Chapin, Emmy Scott Joplin,
even Emmy Navajo music.
And the scary part is that much of it
as quite good Emmy Navajo music. Yeah.
Um, I guess we should
sign off, right? Yes.
I'm just still thinking about Emmy
Navajo music acts. You know what?
Let's let Emmy take us out.
This is actually a your favorite
composer as re animated by Emmy,
the Computer Mahler, Emmy Mahler.
Oh Damn. You know, this is, it's
very troubling. This is very chaplain
[inaudible].
And for more information on anything
you've heard this hour, check our website,
radio lab. Dot. Oregon. While you're
there. Communicate with us. Radio
lab@wnyc.org is the address. This
is Radiolab. I'm Jad Abumrad,
Robert Krulwich and I am signing off.
Okay, here we go.
Radiolab is produced by Jad Abumrad
and Alan Horn with help from Jera
Pellegrini, Sally Hachette,
Melissa Kibo, David Margin,
Michael Shelley, amber
Seely, Laura Vitali,
and special thanks to Eileen Delahunty,
John Elliott challenged Rubin Caudelie,
and also special thanks to me,
Diana Deutsch.
Radiolab is produced by New York
public radio and distributed by NPR.
Okay.